pour oublier les foires ivoire
vous avez envie ce pas pour oublier
ouais de fois vous vivez un petit
chagrin ya beaucoup de problèmes il ya
les parents il ya le travail aussi après
rappeler qu'il ya des problèmes
sentimentaux c'est pas facile du tout a
dit je crois que c'est la période de la
vie où on s'aperçoit qu'il ya des
problèmes on sort de l'enfance et puis
tant qu'on on arrive dans un monde dont
on connaît absolument rien
l'avenir est incertain pour vous vous
avez peur à tous beaucoup vous voyez
comment plus tard vous avez peur
les autres aussi c'est un rapport aux
parents par rapport à la vie par rapport
à la vie pourquoi la vie elle voulait
elle vous apparaît comme très dur pour
tout le monde
il ya beaucoup de chômage en france donc
même pour les étudiants qui sortent
d'une école beaucoup de chômage se sera
égale pour nous ici encore de trois ans
sera pareil et vous quel est le problème
le plus grand pour vous je crois que
c'est surtout dû trouver du boulot après
est-ce que vous avez l'impression d'être
dans un milieu favorisé ou dans un
milieu où c'est plus difficile que
d'autres favoris j'ai je pense qu est ce
que font vos parents vous sont brouillés
et si je suis à l'école c'est que c'est
pour moi c'est pour moi l'avenir tandis
que j'ai des copains n'ont pas la
possibilité d'y aller donc pour un mois
ils sont défavorisés pourquoi ils n'ont
pas la possibilité
les parents vous savez il ya des parents
qui ont une situation intenable qui
n'ont pas les moyens de payer des études
c'est un petit peu inhabituel de voir
une fille devant machine comme celle ci
plus ça va plus on a c'est pas parce
qu'on est une femme qu'on doit pas être
sur nos machines
pourquoi avez vous choisi ce métier ben
moi je ne vais pas choisi
on m'a mis ici parce que je ne savais
pas ce que je les fais je n'avais
vraiment pas encore mes responsabilités
est ce que je voulais faire mes parents
ne voulaient pas qu'est ce que vous
pouviez faire je le laisse faire un bep
sanitaire et social mais c'était à soit
à paris soit dhr donc il fallait que
vraiment je quitte mes parents et mes
parents moi j'ai choisi mais je savais
pas jusqu'à ce que j'allais faire ici on
m'avait dit on m'avait parlé de
l'atelier tout mais pour parler de la
mécanique c'est pas les maths bon moi je
savais ce que c'était ça peut pas même
programme quand troisième essai tout cas
très beau plus tard je sais pas bah moi
après ma troisième après des tests
psychologiques on m'a dit que c'est
préférable que suivant l'enseignement
technique
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
pas plus mal qu'autre chose comment vous
voyez votre avenir
et
à vrai dire je ne vois pas tellement est
ce que vous connaissez des les
adolescents qui ont des problèmes
vraiment des grands problèmes dans leurs
familles ou alors même qu'ils qui n'ont
même plus de famille je connais un
garçon est il resté en dehors de chez
lui pendant une dizaine de jours ils
couchaient d'autrui car parce que son
père le maltraiter tout ça il la baptise
alors il est parti de chez lui ce qui
n'est plus resté coi nouveaux
investisseurs sans cesse
son malheureux c'est vraiment rien on a
des divergences avec mes parents mais
c'est tout ce qu'il ya comme du coup
c'est à dire que je m'entends colle pas
du tout avec mon père on n'a pas le
mandat c'est à dire par là même
caractère il y en a aussi un lapointe
qui cédera chaque fois que je rentre
chez moi c'est la bagarre ça se termine
que je m'en vais unis je me couchais où
j'ai dû arrêter le prince
on en vient à la drogue vous connaissez
des jeunes qui se drogue
oui je connais quelques-uns mais
maintenant c'est vraiment dès lors
c'était des jeunes ils ont ils ont 30
ans avant d'avoir la vente et la drogue
je sais que je gagnerai jamais ça parce
que ça ne dit rien je suis j'ai pas
vraiment de gros problèmes avec mes
parents je me taperais fraîchement jeu
elle est est ce que veut dire ce qu'il
pense de la drogue en général la drogue
rossellat moyen de s'évader un peu d'un
autre monde que sont nées de la crise
drogue surtout ceux pour les problèmes
soit financiers soient leurs familles ou
pour les mariés se consomme
c'est un moyen de s'évader du vin
autrement que sont polis j'ai essayé
vous n'ont jamais comment on en a de la
drogue temps des camarades qui en a qui
sont dans une classe où il y en a deux
trois tous drogue
si on se laisse entraîner est ce que des
jeunes qui boivent aussi oui
ça vous avez l'air d'en connaître
davantage de au début il voit comme ça
entre copains pour et plus le soir il se
retrouve on peut pas tellement rien a
plaidé alcoolique pour oublier les
foires les déboires non vous avez un
vide pas pour billets ouais vous vivez
un petit changement d'emploi sont donc
en pro chez les adolescents boivent
on peut dire une chose qu'il faut
approcher eu d'abord
l'adolescent grain de café ils demandent
une passion alcoolisées on y donne six
fois sur dix c'est
je vois le problème chez moi dans le
café je vois les deux chefs rebelles
commencent par boire encore pas de cela
souvent ils finissent à ils boivent
moins 10 a perdu comme ça
c'est pourquoi si l'habitude disons que
les problèmes de la licence c'est des
problèmes qui sont donnés à cause d'une
société dans laquelle on vit dans une
société dans laquelle on ne voudrait pas
être c'était qu'il nous plaît pas
[Musique]